they cannot leave the 2020 draft without
what chris
i i think there's you know there's two
positions that jump out to me when i
look at the seattle seahawks you know
first off like cornerback position jumps
out to me a little bit you know just
like we saw aaron rodgers on a big third
and down in the late games they couldn't
cover man-to-man and get off the field
that's kind of been their mo they don't
have a guy that they can play man-to-man
and stop other teams really good
receivers but
i'm not gonna go there i'm going to say
pass rusher once again yes jededian
clown is there ziggy yanza not there
genevieve connie not there excuse me
that's what i meant to say and this is a
seattle scheme as you know which i'm a
little critical of sometimes because i
think it's a little
uh you know just there's not enough
variety in the scheme itself it's it
relies on that pass rush and yes they
drafted lj collier last year in the
first round from tcu you know and he had
some injury issues but they still need
more pass rushers there's no doubt about
that now it doesn't have to be in the
first round but i look at that as a
position still to make seattle's defense
successful right now you know they got
some good defensive linemen i don't know
if they got one guy that you would be
worried about coming off the edge so i'm
gonna go with pass rusher
yeah i agree with you i mean davey and
clown has been a free agent for over a
month now there's no indication he's
gonna resign with the seahawks and look
i i if
you got to bring it to a head before the
draft if you're the seahawks we're
either going to get this guy back or
we're not and there was some reporting
recently from mike garafolo of nfl
network that that it's slim and none the
chances of clowning going back to
seattle so pass rush becomes your top
need and and and look the tradition in
seattle has been trade down trade down
trade down and when you look at a
surprising number of needs for a playoff
team and a perennial contender
right you should trade down and get more
picks when you're paying 35 million
starting quarterback you need as many
guys as you can chris who are making the
bargain basement rookie minimum salaries
so get more picks get more get more
lottery tickets that you can scratch off
and hope you find a winner and the one
thing we know about the seahawks john
schneider can find obscure guys in the
later rounds of the draft to become
players and peach carroll pete carroll
can coach them up into good players and
i think that's what they need to do more
of as long as they're paying russell
wilson
more than any team is paying any
quarterback this is going to be part of
their formula every year trade down get
more picks address your needs and hope
you can take some guys we've never heard
of and turn them into household names
yeah that's exactly right i mean they're
special that way seattle's like new
england when they trade down you just go
uh oh oh that just means they're gonna
get more value signings more good
players so you know i'm i'm with you
there mike they're smart and uh they
know what to do there's some good
there's some good pass rushers to be had
later on in the draft they might not be
great all around players yet but good
pass rushers nonetheless
all right we got to get through the rest
of this division pretty good i know we
do 49
cannot leave the draft without what
all right well you know i'm a little
worried about joe staley right a left
tackle there's the the talk about him
maybe you know retiring you don't know
how much longer he's gonna last so
that's in the conversation but i think
the biggest thing to me mike is this
cornerback you know richard sherman we
know he's still good but he's getting up
there in years and then when you really
look at the rest of the position you
just go who else is it there you know
hey ej mosely get a nice player kind of
messed up that play in the super bowl
that cost them you know aquila with
those sproons been up and down they got
no consistency there out of that
position so i look as corner as being a
a def a definite need for this 49ers
team which you know of course has a very
good roster
hey i'm not looking to pick a fight
gratuitously with my good friend richard
sherman but the 49ers recently brought
back jason verrette who had injury
issues last year
when verret was first signed last year
there was a palpable buzz
that if verret worked out
sherman was gone last year from the
49ers now he rebounded and had a great
season but i feel like they're looking
for a reason to move on that's just my
feeling they're looking for a reason to
move on from him and whether you do it
through draft picks whether you do it
through guys you sign a free agency
don't be stunned if it happens and again
this isn't gratuitous this is what i've
heard consistently over the course of
the last year and chris maybe this is
the year they find a corner uh some way
somehow that ends up supplanting richard
sherman
well yeah i mean they're in a good spot
they're not like desperate like oh we
gotta have a guy in here right now where
our defense isn't gonna
we're not gonna be able to succeed no
you know they're still going to be
really good you know whoever it is but
yeah they'll have some flexibility if
they do draft a corner in the first
round or in the second round and so you
know something like that i don't think
they have a second round pick right now
you know but later on you know he's not
gonna have to be thrown into the fire
and have to start right away day one uh
because i think there is enough talent
there at least to make them feel good
but they got to start thinking about the
future a little bit and i just think
they can upgrade the overall talent of
their the room the the cornerback room
all together
they picked up an extra first round pick
with deforest buckner trade but they
don't have a second round pick due to
last year's d4 trade they lost a three
and a four for the emmanuel sanders
trade and he's gone already he's with
the saints via free agency and there's
talk that john lynch the gm of the team
wants to move down and replenish some of
those middle round picks and they have
the ability to move down with picks
number 13 and 31. all right the rams
can't leave the draft without what chris
man the rams got some holes okay they
definitely do i mean they're another
team you got to think about tackle a
little bit with jason whitworth they
might have some young guys they trust i
think that the big one that jumps out to
me though is linebacker mike you know
that's where i look at them right now
and just go who the hell are their
linebackers i mean you know when you
really look at it i don't think just you
know i had to sit here and go oh yeah i
remember that guy oh okay yeah oh yeah
man oh they traded for kenny young last
year you know when they made that trade
with marcus peters it got him at
linebacker so they need you know clay
matthews being gone dante fowler being
gone and now corey littleton gone and
free agency to the oakland raiders they
need a stand-up middle linebacker more
than anything but certainly wouldn't be
hurt by somebody on the edge either but
mostly middle linebacker is their
biggest need
no first round pick due to the jalen
ramsey trade a guy they still haven't
signed to a new contract and you know
it's funny when you think about the
options that the jaguars had last year
to trade ramsey the eagles the
ravens i think were mentioned um
the jaguars picked the right team
because it's starting to feel like the
rams are in the process of falling apart
which is gonna drive those picks up
higher that the jaguars are getting it's
gonna be a real challenge for the rams
to hold it together no brandon cooks no
todd gurley and it's all on jared goff's
shoulders all right very quickly the
cardinals can't leave the draft without
what
well i think the biggest thing i'm going
to say here is corner again they need
they need depth at the corner position
they need players i mean this was the
second worst pass defense in football
okay you know and again patrick peterson
you know it wasn't great last year when
he came back from his suspension and
it's year 10 if i'm if i uh if i
remember correctly so again play is
going to fall down there and i i think
you know there's there's some guys on
their roster at that position where i
just go uh i'm not so sure about that
guy he's unproven i know they traded for
robert alford but he's towards the
downslope of his end of his career too i
think they signed him as a free agent so
i'm going cornerback with the arizona
cardinals
so what you're saying you're surprised
that a guy who was suspended six games
for ped use and for masking ped use
wasn't the same guy when he came back
without the peds is that what you're
telling me well you know me mike you
know that pisses me off there's no other
way to say it yes i don't like it yeah i
know how to stick the fork in your ribs
all right we gotta stick a fork in this
segment i agree with you they need back
uh help at cornerback
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports